ma se io mi nutro e giovanni si nutre
perché frank sinatra ella favi ti seguo
da quando non dicevi cagate 20 ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo io sono poi
genio e ci siamo su un nuovo episodio di
io parlo di cose su rocket link allora a
parte gli stessi visto che tanto la
gente più liberi link clicca per il
probabilmente il titolo non voglio far
passare troppo tempo
scusami amico mio mi dispiace ai ragazzi
oggi parliamo del aspetta che è perfetto
attenzione questa poi servono no questo
attraversa tira compagno tira come
sapete in italia sono importanti tre
cose allora 1 il cibo 2 la famiglia ma
prima di queste due cose ma il primo
posto il calcio in italia è molto
importante il calcio è il calcio va
sopra qualsiasi cosa no va sopra la
politica ma soprattutto cava che poi
l'ha fatto perché l'italiano
all'italiano piace il calcio e allora
qual è secondo voi una delle domande più
frequenti che la gente mi paga quando ho
aperto il canale non è quanto guadagno
non è se ho una ragazza ma la domanda
principale è famiglie che squadra tifi
non c'entra assolutamente nulla con
quello che faccio che non faccio video
di calcio c'è ma ho fatto si fa una
volta due perché ho limonato un cane
provano tris parte
comunque io il calcio non è la cosa che
si avvicina di più al calcio nel mio
canale punto rocket livio che non c'è
non è proprio non è proprio però fai
qualcosa se sei porta fai qualcosa ti
prego muoviti almeno nonostante questo
la domanda viene fatto che spesso è che
squadra tipo va bene la risposta a
questa domanda che devo assolutamente
particolare se noi video dura due
secondi quindi devo articolarla per
farlo durare 10 che squadra ti fa fra i
j
la risposta è nessuno cioè senza allora
vi spiego in realtà la mia famiglia
essendo torinese può tifare o il torino
la juventus perché sono di torino quindi
una delle due
tecnicamente se si dovesse andare su una
è ovvio che non era ovvio ma lo dico io
che si tratta della juve ma ma ma la
verità è che io il calcio non lo seguo
quindi non lo so cioè nel senso io non
so neanche simpatizzo per quella squadra
lì ma non so neanche ci gioca ronaldo
quello lo so ma non so nient'altro se ci
giocano io non vi so dire la formazione
della juve cioè per farvi capire non
seguo il calcio quindi la dura risposta
la domanda che sbaglia vpn su una
partita di calcio non lo seguo non sono
vero tifoso non possono essere
considerato un tifoso se la mia squadra
non la conosco neanche cioè nel senso mi
vien da dire quella perché tutti i miei
amici tifano quella perché ho sempre
sentito parlare di quella squadra lì in
casa mia ma non
non si parla di caldo io non so non so
niente di calcio ora per farvi un
esempio ci sono un sacco di miei amici
che mi dicono sapendo che io no come se
io ti fa si juve tutto il giorno siccome
io vivo a milano conosco un sacco di
persone che tifano inter e milan
quindi il sacco di persone mi quando la
juve perde per un americano è no allora
ecco e stai oggi e io bene verso la tua
juve è ruben rubate rubate bastano bene
non sapesse di mer non sono anche chigi
bastard quindi io mi ritrovo a dover
litigare con persone che però non me ne
frega niente se per da juve
io non ho questa cosa del dell'astio nei
confronti delle altre squadre non me ne
frega niente ma a stento su chi gioca
nella juve anzi vi faccio vedere
toh guarda guarda guarda come strumento
è visto questo un interista lo farebbe
mai per uno juventino c'è piuttosto si
radica la pelle il discorso è uno questa
domanda che sorge spontanea è i favi ad
aver la maglia dell'inter
perché quando ho fatto guido con
nainggolan nainggolan mi ha regalato
l'inter in realtà non regola l'inter mi
ha regalato la maglia dell'inter lo
scritto voi vj e ciò anche la firma di
nainggolan qua dietro io io rispetto
tutte le specifiche fossi un tifoso vero
quando una squadra gioca in champions
league e roba del genere io tiferei
quella squadra se italiana perché io
tifo le squadre italiane non c'è per me
sono quel tifoso che non segue talmente
non segue per niente e quindi io tifo
l'italia tutto e per tutto cerco di
trovare sempre il buono nelle partite
qui sono un buono che ti fa tutte la
situazione siano italiane però non ho
astio nei confronti di nessuno cosa che
invece in italia c'è quindi puoi tenere
tranquillamente il tasso etico
iscriviti attivo perché non stai
sbagliando persona con cui parlare di
calcio e non capiscono se ciò che per
gli italiani questa cosa che sto dicendo
è molto si dice dissapori tantum e
sicily italiano di più alexa traduce in
italiano di sa point ed è grazie mi
chiedo ogni giorno di più il perché ti
ho comprata alexa molto avendo poco
orgoglioso la mia patria e la parola in
questo preciso momento però rende poco
orgogliosa la mia patria che pensa solo
al calcio ragazzi ci tengo a precisare
non sono di quelli che dicono
oh ma il calcio fa schifo perché i
giocatori vengono pagati milioni per
correre dietro un pallone che in realtà
è vero però se ci pensi se una persona
guadagna dei soldi e perché se li sta
meritando a meno che non vada a rubare
in quel caso no però se una persona
viene pagata per fare una roba e viene
pagata in modo corretto e perché
effettivamente se li sta meritando
perché sennò quei soldi li potresti
prendere tu però se quei soldi non li
prendi tu vali prende lui e perchè vista
a fare qualcosa che tu non sai fare
sono riprendere istituto è un discorso
molto studio ritengo studi delle persone
che dicono eh ma perché corre dietro una
palla prende i migliori perché funziona
così mondo dell'intrattenimento perché
la fine il calcio è uno sport e
intrattenimento io sono stato retrocesso
a platino perché faccio pagare però
questo natri scorso però ragazzi c'è non
è un discorso a sensori con ss che ci
sono tante allora profeta allora un per
me un carabiniere dovrebbe guadagnare
quattro volte tanto anche un vigile del
fuoco perché fanno una roba dove mettono
a rischio la propria vita dove sono del
i veri eroi quindi quando tutto il
discorso che io a secondo però il mondo
dell'intrattenimento funziona in modo
diverso perché una persona viene pagata
se sa fare cose che altri non sanno fare
perché sennò altre persone sarebbero suo
posto nel non ci sono un po anche il
discorso the youtuber se ci pensate ci
sono tanti youtubers che fanno tanti
soldi ma perchè perchè la gente dice
facile fare coi video che fanno lì
potrei fare anche io le ho fatte le tute
riesce a fare però filati che se fossi
gradi farli saresti 2 al posto di di
quelli youtuber me compreso sto
scherzando non è vero no sto scherzando
però ragazzi barco il demonio comunque
se andando un po topic
dicevo si trattava le separa di un
argomento basilare il calcio in realtà
non è neanche troppo vero che non lo
seguono lo seguo ma solo le partite
importanti ad esempio i mondiali
li seguo gli europei li seguo ogni volta
la champions league
la seguo nel calcio c'è una roba che mi
dà fastidio che faccio pagare o che nel
calcio si è sempre stata la roba che mi
ha sempre dato fastidio il pareggio cioè
io il pareggio in uno sport non lo
sopporto cioè io non sopporto il
pareggio con il tennis
a me piace tantissimo perché non c'è il
pareggio cene senza qualcuno deve per
forza vincere ea me questa cosa piace io
in uno sport
oddio il pareggio cioè per me per dare
una partita che finisce in pareggio è
come aver buttato il mio tempo non so se
ragazzi molti di voi si ritrovano in
questa cosa ed è proprio per questo
motivo che io guardo la champions league
le eliminatorie e dico ai mondiali e le
europei perché qualcuno deve vincere per
forza di questa cosa piace
effettivamente come quando c'è una
partita dove potrebbe finire in pareggio
non non mi da quel brivido del cavolo
devo vincere a tutti i costi perché ho
vinco perdono o vinco perdo pareggio è
un'arma molto molto mia in realtà è
perché la teca c'è seguitissimo che col
pareggio però una roba mia me non piace
quindi calcio per me a questo limite
limite che non ha ad esempio il tennis
che non a rocket league
anche nel mio piccolo tipo anche se
gioco qua non a questo limite qua o
vinci o perdi perché si va ai golden
goal è una roba che mi è sempre piaciuto
infatti preferisco proprio giocar bene
le partite di calcio a pezzo a fifa
perché lì in genere non la facchineri
pareggio va ai supplementari o robe del
genere e quindi tutto ha tutto un altro
sapore la vita quando c'è di mezzo la
sconfitta ma non rendiamo questo video
filosofico che sto sempre giocando
rocket league con la testa di del mondo
quindi ragazzi il titolo click bait ha
avuto sua risposta quindi non era click
bait però non si può dire che io tifi
juventus quindi non avete motivo di
schiacciare il tasto di iscriviti perché
io non tifo juventus io non tifo niente
presente sono nato nel posto dove tutti
tifano la juve ma è un caso perché ci
sono anche quelli che il calcio non lo
seguono poi sottoscritto ma chissà se
sta roba si replica anche su youtube
chissà se ci sono gli youtube i fan
degli youtubers occasionali
chi segue gli youtubers solo a volte ci
summer i fan che mi seguono occasionali
per caso qualche vostro amico andato in
giro a dire seguo fa vigeva data non mi
stava seguendo
che va tanto per farsi bello rom e le
gesta sono sempre chiesta e soprattutto
i video di fa vj ricordatevi che non
possono finire in pareggio qualcuno
vince sempre e quello sono io
l'altra domanda che viene posta sempre
molto su moto in modo molto molto molto
sovente volevo far vedere questo gol
quindi ho allungato di molto e se sono
fidanzato o meno però non avrebbe senso
rispondere a questa domanda in questo
video perché ho già click day dato sulla
faccenda del che squadra tivo ragazze
che state guardando questo video
interessava l'un per cento di voi non è
vero anche la ragazza secondo al calcio
so che probabilmente ci sono più ragazze
che seguono il calcio che youtubers
perché tutti youtubers che conosco non
seguono il calcio
tranne stormi la partita abbiamo fatto i
culi quindi chi segue il calcio sarà
anche contento ho fatto tre gol
evitate vi prego di farmi questa domanda
perché ogni volta sono imbarazzato nel
dirvi che non so neanche chi è il
capitano della juventus che il capitano
dell'interno che il capitano dista cebà
quindi non lo so sta partita è finita ed
è veramente orribile continuarla
infierire quindi lasciamo perdere gli
sia piaciuto come religiosi video
bisogno solo quanto mi piace scrivere al
canale schiacciano la campanella per
essere aggiornati sono in biogas con e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video che parliamo di cose da ragazzi
[Musica]